okay good evening everybody we will make
a start with
um tonight's meeting of executive which
is largely
um a deferral of the items that were
listed
um for a previous exec that needed to be
canceled if we can begin with
attendances just to note that councilor
Harding may make it to the meeting but
has been representing the council at the
launch of the Ukraine exhibit at the
Imperial War Museum so she is on her way
walking through the rain to get here
um as soon as she can and apologies also
from councilor new item two is questions
from members of the public I'm not aware
that any have been received item three
is Declarations of Interest are there
any Declarations of interest in any of
the items on the agenda
no no could Oak item for James
sorry just to declare that I'm a member
of the board for arms of Trafford for
the Tamworth development thank you later
okay that's the Declaration I used to
make so I was waiting for it
um item four is minutes
um so we have before is the next the
meeting on the 25th of July
um can we approve those please
thank you item five is Matters from
Council or overview and scrutiny
committees not seeing anybody
here to fill us in there but I guess
they will do so at Council if needed
item Six coming to councilor Williams on
the consultation results for the um
mayor's challenge fund Crossing
proposals at Dunham road and gorsey Lane
thank you chair and in the interest of
time as I am conscious that we have full
Council
um immediately after this meeting a
little bit restricted this evening I
can't speak at length to the item as the
report does
um do a pretty good job at outlining the
subject matter and committee members
will recall that in February 2019 a
petition was presented in front of full
Council
um from a student well then students of
altering Wheels grammar school
requesting that consideration be given
for a new pedestrian Crossing to be
installed
um on the a56 by Dunham road the council
has essentially pursued a consideration
of that matter and referred it to
transport for greater Manchester via the
May is challenge fund I'm pleased to be
able to report that consultation was
undertaken with the community and had
received generally favorable responses
so we have pursued the item and
transport for greater Manchester
together working with our highways um
Department have put forward a proposal
which is outlined in the report this
evening for approval thank you chair
thank you councilor Williams any
questions or comments from members of
the executive
questions or comments more widely
councilor wetton please
thank you
um
I just needed to to draw members
attention to some
um aspects within
um within this scheme and these are not
related at all to The Pedestrian
Crossing or the cycle Crossing
um these are concerns that have been
made to me by a significant number of
local residents very local to The
Junction in question and that they're
concerned about the unintended
consequences of of the alterations to
the road layout particularly the loss of
the junction of devisdale Road and the
a56
um
that in itself adds pressure to the
um
Junction of Saint Mary's it's a
Margaret's Road and the a56 but also
devisdale Road and Saint Margaret's road
which is sort of compounding as they're
piling up as as you're getting there
and then the
um the movement of the the bus stop
um onto Saint Margaret's road again
building up up pressure on there so the
the the the the fears are
um expressed by as I say and quite a
number of the local residents about the
traffic issues that that will arise
um by removing that
um important Junction
um uh uh the the devilsdale road
Junction and and all those knock-on
effects
um I've I've made
um
uh a significant representations on this
and I do
um I do believe uh in in my Layman's
approach to it that there is scope to
deliver most of this scheme
um certainly The Pedestrian Crossing at
cycle Crossing
um they're given
um I think other things can be delivered
uh without taking the devastale uh Road
a56 Junction away and I would just
really ask that as this goes forward
that that be given some serious uh
looking at uh by officers it's it's
quite a space to fit
um what we're talking about in into it
it doesn't impact on the initial scheme
of the you know the initial request of
The Pedestrian Crossing of this and
um the cycle Crossing fine
um but as I say I do believe there's
sufficient space there to to at least
meet some of those residents concerns
and and not build pressure uh where
where we don't want it unintended
consequences you find them out once
things are built and then there's no
chance of getting anything uh reversed
so I would just make those that request
and hope that the local residents
um voices are being heard through
through me thank you thanks Council
working Council Williams
thank you chairman thank you councilor
wetton um I I know that you've made
significant representations on this
matter and I think you do
um a great service for the residents of
board who have contacted you
um I did look into the specific
um request in respective the junction of
Devil's Dale Rogan
um my understanding is that was and I
appreciate you've just
um advised committee that um
removing that aspect wouldn't impact on
the initial request of The Pedestrian
Crossing but what it would do is
prohibit cycling provision now as this
scheme has been delivered via the
mayor's challenge fund tfgm we're
extremely keen on a facilitating cycle
provision
um so my view is that this wouldn't be
going ahead were it not for
um the the cycling provision being
included in the specific impact there
upon that Junction with devisdale Road I
appreciate that some residents will have
concerns I'd like to think that the
impact on them will not be as
significant as perhaps they are
concerned it will be
um because otherwise I consider this
debut essentially a case of um a
resident has asked and we have delivered
I think it's a very good news story in
the context of extreme austerity that we
find ourselves in thank you
comes to join
thank you leader
um I just wanted to start off by first
congratulating Eleanor who's in
attendance tonight for bringing this
issue forward she did an amazing work
with the petition but she recognized
that hundreds of school children each
morning were facing Peril as they
crossed this road
um and I think the safety improvements
that would be put in place will be a
real big step forward
um so yeah so congratulations again for
for The Splendid work you've done and
it's good to see this game taking
forward the one criticism I would have
is there was a second consultation on
the gorsey lane scheme
um it went out to 369 properties but
only got 19 responses and I think this
slowed down the scheme going forward
quite considerably and I just want to
know why that was allowed to happen
thank you councilor my understanding is
there is a specific request
um that the consultation be extended I
can provide you with a little bit more
information if you give us the time I'm
happy to contact you with an update
thanks Council Williams councilor wetton
Welton rather sorry don't worry it's
happening all the time don't worry
um yes I owe me a similar point to uh my
near name namesake um regarding the
devilsdale but a rather different
suggestion is that the um the scheme as
proposed could be simplified hugely if
um devisdale Road was actually
um was was actually filtered had a
single exit onto groby Road
um and then accessed the main road
network via Saint Margaret's Road rather
than having um you know um currently
it's got It's got an exit at each end
currently on the a56 in these um current
proposals onto Saint Margaret's Road
um and actually it's a very quiet Road
it could easily just be a cul-de-sac
which then um which then filters out
onto out onto groby Road and that would
make the whole Junction design
considerably simpler and I would have
thought quite a lot cheaper as well so
you might want to consider that but I
don't want to hold this up so uh so it's
just something for you for you to think
about but this taken a long time already
thank you very much
uh thanks councilor Welton we will um
note that proposal
um so the recommendations are as set out
in the report I just want to Echo
um Council Jones comments um in
congratulating Eleanor and also
acknowledging that this has taken a very
long time to come forward
um so I am pleased that it is here
um today so with the comments that we
have received
um from Members can the recommendations
be approved please
thank you
item seven is the Tamworth development
update councilor Patel please thank you
leader I'm excited to be able to present
this update on the Tamworth development
a key Brownfield site in Old Trafford
which has been vacant for some years in
partnership with Trafford Housing Trust
we're bringing forward 161 new homes
within a landscape-led scheme that
represents the very best of our
Ambitions in terms of design and place
making
we have undertaken two rounds of public
consultation the scheme has received
significant support
we are committed to delivering 30 of
affordable housing through the
application of a grant from homes
England and I would like to draw
attention to paragraph 2.7 which
explains the route we will follow to
achieve this
due to the cost of delivering such a
high quality design scheme the scheme is
submitted to planning shows a profit
margin of only five to six percent which
in commercial terms is considered
commercially unviable
in this scenario it is usual that no
affordable housing requirement is placed
upon a scheme planning stage
funding from homes England will be
applied to the Tamworth development but
this will be done post planning stage in
line with the funders requirements
whilst I appreciate this is a different
approach than is usually taken
we must adhere to homes England's
funding requirements to secure this
additional funding I do know that many
other local authorities are working
through this very same scenario
to add Assurance One of the
recommendations of this report sees us
commit to only approving commencement of
this development through our joint
venture body with Trafford Housing Trust
called homes for Trafford when the house
homes England Grant can be applied
finally I'd like to thank officers and
partners who are working very hard in
very difficult
um in a very difficult commercial
environment to deliver this quality
screen scheme which will bring much
needed family housing to Old Trafford
thank you
thank you councilor Patel any questions
or comments from members of the
executive counselor right
thank you leader and thank you councilor
but I just like to welcome uh this uh
this development I mean it not just as
it provide affordable housing but it
also provides
um sustainable homes that are going to
meet the increasing cost of living
crisis that we Face by reducing energy
bills
um it's a Brownfield site so it meets
our targets from that perspective and I
think it's something to be welcomed and
I look forward to the development
commencing post planning of course thank
you later
thank you councilor Wright and you are
of course holding the ring politically
on the specific
um recommendation to only approve the
commencement of the scheme if we have
that 30 so that is a um a clear decision
that we are taking this evening any
questions or comments more widely Jerome
thank you leader
um first of all I just want to um yeah
um give some Praise on this scheme the
carbon reduction of 70 is is really a
really good Energy Efficiency and a the
raft of measures that are being put in
place are really welcome
um so hopefully that will continue and
we get to carbon zero
eventually in the report it does say
that this would be going to planning
committee in October 2022 but if you
look at the tomorrow's agenda
um it's not on there so I just wondered
is it delayed because of this meeting or
is it delayed for other reasons thank
you
Richard are you able to explain that I
suspect it is that we required the
decision tonight and this was the paper
written for several weeks ago but uh no
just to be clear the the paper is that
the planning application will be
submitted in October and go to January
23 planning application so that's what
we're working on
okay thanks uh councilor wetton
I'd like to just uh offer a comment of
support on this
um those poor members who sat through
years of planning committee with me on
it may well remember that I um welcomed
uh most schemes virtually every scheme
that created new homes in Trafford and
um although this is ahead of the
planning process and I hope I'm not
technically myself any future
opportunities uh I certainly welcome
this it's good to see a scheme of this
size taking place on on making good use
of a site
thank you thanks councilor went it
certainly shows what we can do when we
work in uh in partnership with our
strategic Partners in Trafford so the
recommendations are as set out in the
report can they be approved please
and Q item eight is the real living wage
progress update councilor Carter please
thank you leader
you know it's been a long held ambition
to help our providers pay the real
living wage to all their staff so we
conducted a survey in August this year
and this paper is an update on that
position
so we can see there's been a
considerable Improvement in the older
people's care market and 100 of our home
care providers now pay the real living
wage to their Care staff which is up
from 70 in January
the picture is more mixed in residential
and nursing care with 21 out of 32 Care
Homes paying real living wage but that
means the third of the market or not
however this is a big Improvement since
January when only a third of providers
were paying it
in daycare services for people with
learning disabilities and older people
yet again 100 are paying as are the
majority of our learning disability
supported living providers
we've also got an independent company
who are undertaking our work on the fair
cost of care which is required by the
dhsc and that will help us understand
the real costs um of providing care
we previously agreed in February that we
would progress the real living wage
accreditation process which will take
time but a working group is progressing
key activity for accreditation
so I recommend to the executive
um that they know the significant
process that's been made by the social
care sector in paying the real living
wage thank you
thank you councilor Carter any questions
or comments from members of the
executive councilor Slater please
um I'd just like to um
thank you and and the staff for all the
hard work that we've that's gone into
actually achieving this because it isn't
just a walk in the park to be able to
and get that that's that sorted in the
short period of time that we've been
looking at it you know if kovid showed
us anything and it showed us that our
care workers are our front line really
and um I think it's um you know it's
really welcomed that those people will
be getting a real living wage so thank
you for all the hard work
thank you councilor Slater any other
questions or comments from members of
the exact questions or comments more
broadly
report is just for noting as counselor
Slater says it is
um very welcome and thank you councilor
Carter and also councilor Harding for
the work that she's done previously
um to get us to the point that we are at
with this
um
it's just for noting can that be noted
please
thank you
um and that brings us then to item nine
budget monitoring
2022-23 period for councilor Ross please
thank you leader this feels like quite
an out of date paper now but I'll go
through the uh as it was at the end of
July this year the the top line as at
the end of July was the outcome pressure
of 6.91 million
part of that 6.91 million was an
estimate for inflation if you and if you
remove that estimate the over to the
overspend projected at this that stage
is 912 000 pounds which is in keeping
with a previous uh budget monetary
reports at this stage of the game
um and it is also a 1.13 million pound
Improvement since the period 2 report
was published key pressures to note are
the pressures on homeschool transport of
980 000 pounds that is a combination of
the numbers of passengers the cost of
fuel and the complexity of cases the
Strategic investment program there's a
projection of uh it bringing in 1.56
million pounds lower than expected in
the budget though we do have a good
pipeline still to uh to to review as
part of the investment management
strategy for the rest of the year
in terms of movements the other way
um the bank of England base rate that
took place before the previous the the
most recent Bank of England based rate
um gave us a 850 000 pound boost to uh
the level of investment income generated
by uh Surplus cash
um balances that the council holds so
that that is the interest rate that was
happened in the summer before the the
recent one that took place last month
and obviously before any future interest
rates are um born in mind
um
the current out so the note the capital
program
incorporates the impact of inflation and
increased borrowing costs with an impact
on the revenue budget that comes in that
way as well so as I say it does feel
like a long time ago but happy to take
any questions or comments about the P4
monitor thank you
thank you councilor Ross any questions
or comments from members of the
executive
questions or comments more widely
councilor Myers please
[Music]
yes thank you leader I noticed that the
uh excuse me
I noticed that the council tax support
scheme the drawdown on it was actually
better than anticipated
um what are the uh what's the view of
what will happen uh during the winter
months
um in terms of council tax support
obviously we're about to head into what
could be quite a difficult uh winter for
people we could be looking at a
situation where you'll have seen the
growth figure that was published for one
month today but it doesn't point to a
particularly Rosy picture for the
economy so it may well be that more is
drawn on the the council's tax support
as we head into the winter months
obviously you've seen the note that the
notice today about the cost of living
response that the council are having all
this feeds into that but certainly if
people were to be in a situation where
they have to access council tax support
that is there for them to access and
we'll make sure that we look after
families in that situation across
Trafford if that does happen
ideally it wouldn't happen but we have
to be realistic with how the economy is
at the moment and the potential for
unemployment
and councilor Watton
just a couple of comments uh really
first here I'd like to say in this forum
uh that I'm always very impressed by uh
our officers especially with the
production of this report and the
um finger on the pulse monitoring that
they clearly demonstrate in this report
and I've always found it a very useful
piece of information
um obviously it doesn't take a um a
crystal ball to suspect a roller coaster
uh year this year to date as we go as we
go through it
um and there will be some um
pleasing moments where um budget
Provisions are released and can and and
can benefit the picture
um but very likely there will be some
unknown unknowns um this year and
um as I've already said I know our
officers have got the fingers on the on
the pulse
um and hopefully those are not going to
be
um
maybe there won't be any but if there
are any let's hope they're not too
problematic but we certainly are in
difficult times and
um and it's um
it's only responsible to recognize that
by all sides thank you
thanks councilor Watson councilor Ross
yep just to to Echo thanks to our
officers we are very lucky in this
Authority that we do have some superb
officers in the finance team who do
produce very timely very clear reports
monitoring reports throughout the year
and one of those things inflation is
something that obviously we saw as a
potential concern earlier this year and
created the inflation risk Reserve which
we have added to over the course of the
year as the impacts of fuel prices and
obviously um the changes to to ages as
well feed into the current budget but I
yeah I appreciate your comments and I
know that I share them when it comes to
the caliber of our offices in that team
so thank you
Council drawing
thanks leader I just quickly wanted to
mention the paragraph about electric
vehicle charging points and it said your
work is still underway with the GM
approved partner
um but it does say that the investment
required may increase beyond the
council's approved program and I just
wonder with the increase in Energy
prices whether the EV scheme could be
running into the
councilor Ross
um
it's as far as I'm I'm concerned no it's
not running into difficulty um it is
something that we're actively exploring
as we bring forward our draft budget
proposals um shortly I don't know if
anyone would like to add anything else
yeah actually the the challenge with the
rollout of that program has been about
connecting into the electricity Supply
rather than the cost of electricity
that's been uh more challenging than we
anticipated it it being and that's given
us some challenge to it we're actively
looking for other other sites so that's
where the pressure is coming from
um rather than electricity costs and
what we are committed to advancing the
rollout of that program as we've ordered
this to a long line along the lines of
the current program
[Music]
okay not seeing any other questions or
comments
um and the monitor is just for noting
albeit as counselor Ross said slightly
out of date at this point can that be
noted please
thank you item 10 is urgent business of
which there is none item 11 is the
exclusion resolution
um which I will read out as I always do
that the public be excluded from this
meeting during consideration of the
remaining items on the agenda because of
the likelihood of disclosure of exempt
information which Falls within one or
more descriptive category or categories
of the Local Government Act in 1972
schedule 12a as amended by the local
government access to information
variation order 2006 and specified on
the agenda item or report relating to
each such item respectively so I will
move that is that agreed please
okay so if we are able to move into
closed session and end the video
recording that would be
helpful